(glitchy music)
- Here he is.
That's Dan Morrison.
- Who's that?
- That's the guy Busy cheated with.
(aggressive rock music)
- Wait, dude, okay, look,
listen, this is not a good idea.
Okay, I know what you're doing,
I know I said I wanted crazy *mashback,
but this is the wrong way to go, dude.
- [Jason] I'll be right back, Walter.
- No, no, no, no, no.
It's a bad idea, dude!
- [Jason] Hey!
- Hey, dog, funny.*
- Yeah, you can tell me
how this tastes for lunch!
- Oh!
- [Andy] Oh, my God,
dude, are you all right?
- What the fuck, man?
Why'd you hit me?
- Stay away from my wife, Dan.
- Dan?
Dan, you gotta get out of here.
- I'm not Dan, I'm Bill.
- [Dan] I'm almost done with this--
- [Jason] Huh?
- [Bill] I'm not Dan, I'm Bill!
- Oh my God, oh my God, what
did you do, what did you do?
Are you all right, Bill?
- He hit me, he hit me!
- Oh, my God, you got the wrong guy.
I'm Dan, this is Bill.
- [Bill] Oh.
- [Dan] You hit the wrong guy.
- [Bill] What did you do this for?
- You hit a guy with cancer.
He's got cancer.
- Really?
- Yes.
- But I--
- We met a ton of times.
You don't recognize me?
- Really?
- Yeah, like 20, you came to my wedding.
- [Jason] I did?
- Yes!
You came to my wedding.
- [Jason] I don't remember.
- Are you that self-involved, Jason, huh?
That you don't even recognize
the guy you're beating up?
- Well, listen, you guys, I
mean, you look exactly alike.
- Not really, actually.
- No, not at all.
- We look nothing alike,
just 'cause we're bald?
- Shut up, Walter.
- Yeah, you could throw me in, am I--
- Yeah, do we look alike?
- All right, that's enough.
Okay, you shut it right now.
You fooled around with my wife.
And that's unacceptable.
Unacceptable to me.
I'm sorry I hit your
friend who has cancer.
- It's okay, I just lost
my cool for a second.
You know what, I'm in
remission five years,
thank God for that.
- Five years?
I mean, you don't really
have cancer anymore, right?
You're kinda--
- Yes, it's cancer.
- Of course it's cancer.
- Just, I live a life of fear.
- [Walter] You're kinda
in the clear, though.
I mean, right?
- I'm not in the clear.
- [Walter] You're kinda
milking it a little, no?
- You do kinda use it
as a crutch sometimes.
- All right, that's enough, that's enough!
Okay, well, you stay away
from my wife, all right?
You got that?
- Yes.
- Okay?
- Of course.
- Or I'll come back, I hit
your friend in the face again,
who may or may not have cancer.
- He has--
- I have cancer.
- Definitely, definitely has it.
- Not as much anymore.
- Okay, you know what, you can
just calm down, Andy, okay?
(upbeat music)